i try to be an optimist even in these uh
dark times
uh and one of the things i want to talk
about is ever since covet started
everyone
has been trapped inside and you know
what i say that's a great time to take
up
a new hobby look at the positive great
time to pick up a hobby
so i've taken up an incredible new hobby
i am really excited to share with you
guys
i'm going to show you in a segment
called conan's
new hobby
[Music]
okay check this out i've been getting
into
origami look at this guy a little frog
right there pretty cool huh and i got a
a
bird right here a kind of a crane sort
of gull
and then a little um i don't know
flower what do you think andy
they're nice but i mean they they're a
little underwhelming let's just say that
okay it's just that i'm still learning
you know i just started
well i mean it's just it's kind of
disappointing especially after that
you know exciting intro package it just
sort of i expected more
yeah you know honestly i i didn't know
about the intro
i i didn't i didn't think they'd make
such a huge deal about it
and then they made that crazy intro and
it's just hard to follow i know well
i mean frankly you kind of let us all
down
[Music]